hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
you might remember a couple of weeks ago
i did a dear apple video dear apple
please refresh
the mac pro
please so then yesterday we got a rare
insight from apple about a product that
they're working on but not revealing
just yet which turns out to be a new mac
pro that's coming um so i don't want to
say that apple watched my video or phil
schiller definitely saw it but you know
the message got echoed out there and
apple is listening they've got an ear to
the ground so of course that being said
it can't be just apple we have other
companies that we have things to say to
so samsung in the past year or so we've
had a bunch of questions about what's
good with samsung you know obviously
they had the battery issues with the
note 7 and then recently a bunch of
their flagship stuff got leaked into
oblivion but now that it's finally out
and released galaxy s8 is official we
still got some stuff to say to him dear
samsung you don't have to compete
against google with every single little
piece of software that they handle
already they do it really well like
sammy you have such a long reputation
like a long history of using google
software android but then also building
a samsung version of like every single
thing google makes already doesn't this
seem like a really big waste of
resources and time i really thought
about this like samsung's been making
phones for a long time they're smart
they've been doing it well there's got
to be a good reason for why they keep
doing this but i really can't think of
it so now galaxy s8 comes out and it's a
beautiful phone it's got an awesome
camera great looking display phenomenal
design all kinds of awesome specs but
its biggest new software feature is a
new
samsung assistant called bixby and it
has its own button on the side of the
phone let me know if any of this sounds
familiar meet bixby it's a new
intelligent interface that reimagines
the user mobile user experience bixby
understands context it knows what's
happening on your screen but bixby also
learns and adapts to your routine to
anticipate what you need when you swipe
to the right on the home screen bixby
takes you to a contextual personalized
page that shows you the information you
use from the apps you use
on in one convenient place you'll see a
series of cards for native apps like
email and gallery and third-party apps
like facebook and uber and bixby will
organize these cards based on where you
are and what time it is in the morning
you might see news and weather and at
night your alarm and step count and the
more you use it the more it learns
the third part of the new android search
experience
is called google now google now gets you
just the right information at just the
right time
and all of it happens automatically
google now uses things like your search
history your location history and your
calendar to figure out what information
you might need and when you also see a
beautiful header that changes based on
your time and location you also see the
google now cards beneath it your carts
will get smarter and more accurate as
you use them
and we're just beginning okay so if you
haven't already put it together samsung
is now making a super smart bixby
assistant on a phone that runs android
7.0 which means that phone already has
google assistant which has been doing
pretty much all of these things for a
while for a couple years now and really
well but why again like why are they
making the same thing that google's been
making for a while now granted there's a
couple unique things that google
assistant doesn't do right now like the
photo recognition in the camera you can
hold the camera up pointed at something
it'll give you a link to buy it if you
point it at a banana it'll give you a
link to buy a banana whatever i guess
that's kind of cool but overall it just
seems like an unnecessary amount of
effort basically copying something that
google's already done competition is
good but not when you're just copying
something and the product's already free
maybe
maybe let us remap the bixby button
to the google assistant if we want or
let us link it to any app i'm not asking
for a google play edition or anything i
know that's not going to happen but like
it would be actually a legitimate
feature if you had a custom button on
the side of the phone kind of like you
did on that galaxy s7 active where we
could link it to any app we want that
would be a legit awesome feature dear
samsung your first party cases for your
phones
need work the galaxy s8 like i said is a
beautiful phone but with that huge gray
display and really thin bezels on the
top and bottom and sides we obviously
know this phone is going to be a bit
more breakable and susceptible to damage
if it drops they know that they've
tested the phone themselves it's kind of
funny that you can drop your phone in a
pool and it's cool but if you drop your
phone next to the pool not so good
anyway when there's people that get this
phone there's going to be two types of
people one is like me less common but i
won't put a case on it because it's too
beautiful i just got this really nice
fun i want to show it off but number two
is the people who won't use this phone
without a case because it's so delicate
that they don't want to risk breaking it
if they drop it they sign up for a
two-year contract got to get a case this
is your chance samsung to compete with
other manufacturers and make all the
products better you have the dimensions
first you know where the weak points are
on the phone this is your chance to make
the case market really good and this is
the case you come up with
what is that this is
terrible in every way i think every
single way that it can be bad the color
the shape
it's not good oh my god it looks like a
bikini for your phone but like made out
of play-doh it looks like you hired the
guy who designed the iphone 5c case and
like lock them in a room for a month
with like crayons it looks like a
fisher-price case for a fisher-price
phone but it's not really a fisher-price
phone if you know what i mean these need
work samsung serious work so that's
pretty much it just a couple pretty
general requests things i figured we
should talk about things i think we
could get from a company that we like a
lot and who knows maybe someone from
samsung will end up watching this video
in which case
you guys should also keep the headphone
jack around so thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]